is it a crime
is it considered a crime or not are they
getting arrested are they taken in or no
and that's a great question i i like to
talk about this one
no it is not a crime here in the united
states in some countries it is to
attempt suicide it is a crime but not
here and this is what i tell folks and i
think this is very very important
you see people suffering from mental
illness and then law enforcement comes
out and that individual is handcuffed
and people get all up in a roar about
this but i want to tell you something
that folks need to hear and what i would
do is i would tell
the individual in dealing with them when
they were over this rail or wherever i'm
at on the bridge
that especially let's just say over the
rail
when you come back over not if but when
you come back over
i have to place you in handcuffs that's
only for your safety and our policy
that's all it is you're not under arrest
you haven't done anything wrong
so most of the time they have not done
anything wrong they don't have a warrant
so if they come back over i've already
discussed it with them i've never had an
issue
after discussing it with an individual
let me get this straight so i'm on the
the individuals on the verge of jumping
i'm on the other side
not back where i'm safe while i'm on the
other side
you tell me i'm going to bring you over
and i'm going to handcuff you and they
agree to it
i said when you come back over because
they want to know what happens because
now
if they think that they're in trouble
that just compounds everything
they think if they do come back over now
they're going to go to jail now that's
more money that's time away the
embarrassment and everything else
i'm going to knock all that down
and you know what here's what's going to
happen when you come back over first i
congratulate you and talk with you for a
minute
then i have to place you in handcuffs
that's only because it's our policy
but really they're in my hands now i'm
responsible for them
so let's say if i didn't put them in
handcuffs and i put them in a patrol car
and we start driving them down to san
francisco general
and we're going 60 miles down the road
and
they think you know what i don't want to
do this i really
should have jumped or whatever boom now
they're free to kick out the window and
jump out the car 60 miles an hour
whereas if i have them in handcuffs i
have that time to pull over at least
slow down a lot
so it is all about their safety but i
explained this to them and since
i've been doing that i've never had an
issue
kevin since you've been doing this and
you've gone through a few hundred of
these
um do you agree with the current law on
what to do after somebody is suicidal
or would you ever change it would you
change it like
they go get checked out and then the
people let them go and and they go about
their business
would you change the approach maybe they
stay somewhere for a week maybe the
timeline's got to be longer
what would you say because i guess the
main thing is you know the whole
what what is the word they use for
people who go to jail they get on they
get back in again recidivism
so how how often have you seen people
who are suicidal
they come they leave and they come back
and they want to commit to suicide
anyways because they didn't get the
proper need they need the proper
help they needed and that does happen
unfortunately
i would just hope and pray that the
individuals looking at them
really take this into consideration
they're there for a reason you know once
in a while we get these folks
who know the process and they're going
to go over the rail just because they
know we're going to respond
and they'll get three hots in the cotton
out of the cold and out of the wet in
the rain and all
but the vast majority of time these are
folks who are suffering
greatly and if they decide to live that
day we get them past
this crisis boom we want to get them
some help
but it is difficult you know there's not
a lot of money put into mental health
um we need more funding for this for
folks to have
access sometimes they're waiting two
months to get an appointment with a
mental health professional i mean that's
not right if you're in crisis
we need to get help now you know and to
build this and make this a stronger
system
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye